[Musique]
le pavillon réciproque c'est un lieu de
vie transitoire qui a ouvert ses portes
il y a pas très longtemps il y a
quelques semaines et cette semaine et la
semaine prochaine on a les premiers
événements donc à l'occasion de des
événements de Noël en fait on a des
boutiques à l'intérieur des boutiques de
d'artisans locaux
qui sont installés là pendant pendant
deux semaines et qui sont accompagnés
certains jours de la semaine par des
événements
festifs donc là aujourd'hui on a la
fanfare de l'école polytechnique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'idée c'est de comme son nom l'indique
c'est un lieu de vie donc l'idée c'est
de faire vivre ce nouveau quartier c'est
un quartier qui qui a pas encore de gare
mais qui a pas mal d'étudiants pas mal
d'entreprises donc il s'agit de créer de
l'animation de sortir les étudiants de
leurs écoles sortir les salariés aussi
de leur entreprise et puis pourquoi pas
de les faire se rencontrer à l'occasion
d'événements festifs associatifs
culturels et donc en fait aujourd'hui on
amorce ça donc à partir à partir de
janvier on mettra à disposition ce lieu
pour organiser des événements culturels
associatifs ça peut prendre différentes
manières et justement on est dans une
dans une dynamique de co-construction on
a quand même des étudiants qui qui
habitent sur le plateau sur le quartier
Polytechnique qui sont les premiers à
savoir ce dont ils ont besoin en termes
d'équipements et de vie urbaine et donc
l'idée voilà c'était ce familiarise avec
ce lieu là qu'il y passe voilà ce dont
ils ont besoin pour pour se sentir bien
dans ce nouveau quartier qui en devenir
et qui va qui va évoluer au fil des
années
aujourd'hui on a différentes boutiques
donc il y a une association du Liban
quand il fait traiteur et dont les
bénéfices reviendront du coup pour cette
association qui iront qui iront au Liban
on a des bijoux aussi que artisanaux et
du savon
végétal fait par par une une artisan
aussi qui nous vient de Palaiseau
[Musique]